Daniel Quan
and Daniel schweinert won the award for
everything everywhere all at once
and the Daniels dedicated their speech
to tranzing the kids
oh my God thank you sir uh our fellow
nominees you guys are our heroes this is
weird
um uh this we want to dedicate this to
the mommies all the mommies of the world
to our moms uh specifically my mom and
dad Ken and Becky thank you for not
squashing my creativity when I was
making really disturbing horror films or
really perverted comedy films or
dressing in drag as a kid which is a
threat to nobody uh
and uh yeah thank you to everybody who
works on our movie
and by the way there's nothing wrong
with that if a kid is going to be
encouraged to pretend that he's the
opposite sex that's totally great so
says Daniel sheinert I'm told I
mispronounced his name apparently
right now
the libs are saying that it is a
conspiracy theory
to believe that the the Liberals want to
trans the kids that's a crazy conspiracy
theory you can be suppressed on social
media if you say that
and yet we hear it we hear it from Oscar
winners we hear it from the president
previously they told us that the notion
of transgenderism at all there was a
conspiracy theory oh you think just
because we redefine marriage pretty soon
reading a transgenderism that's a
slippery slope crazy fallacy conspiracy
theory
which before that we were told oh you
think just because you're going to
normalize certain eccentric sexual
practices that pretty soon we're going
to redefine marriage that's a crazy
conspiracy theory
before that we were told you think just
because we accept feminism you're going
to get the sexual Revolution and all
sorts of weird crazy Village People
stuff all throughout Society no that's a
crazy conspiracy theory but what do we
know what do we know folks we know
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth used to be three to
six months now I think maybe three to
six days really big historic news
I I can't believe we couldn't get to it
yesterday this should have been the top
of the show of course
um
Michelle yo yo
has become the first person identifying
as Asian
to win the Oscar for best actress
I did not stumble I did not misread that
this is a breaking according to NPR
Michelle yo wins Oscar for best actress
making history as the first person who
identifies as Asian to win the award
okay okay fine I guess we all just
identify we all are simply people who
identify none of us really is anything
at all now the reason they use this
language apparently is that some other
actress had already won the first Asian
actress had already won but she didn't
wear her ethnicity on her chest on a big
sticker that she put on her forehead
that said I am Asian so therefore we now
have to celebrate it again because an
actress who I identifies as Asian wanted
okay this is a much deeper issue though
this is much deeper than racial identity
politics
which is where most of the discussion is
right now
this is an issue of
epistemology which keeps coming up
because that's really what's at the
heart of the transgender debate that's
what and that's in large part why the
transgender debate is
so hot why people care so much about it
it's not because of the handful of
people who throughout history have had
confusion about their sex and want to
pretend to be the opposite sex it's not
even really about the much larger number
of people who are catching on to this
ideology for attention and as a social
contagion it's it's about this question
of epistemology
can we really know anything at all
are can we know that that an actress is
Asian or is the best that we can ever
know that someone identifies as Asian
can we really know anything at all
the for almost all of our civilizations
history
we have believed
that we
can know things and so we take that
knowledge and we move on and we build on
that knowledge and then we build on more
knowledge and we develop what has been
Western Civilization
the new idea is radical skepticism which
says we can really never know anything
at all you know when you're a kid and
you say it's your friend hey what if the
color that you think is blue I what if I
see that color is green oh man what can
we know anything at all man you know
maybe I don't know maybe you had that
conversation as a kid maybe you had it
over a bong when you were a sophomore in
college either way though it expresses
the same idiotic idea
we just can't really know anything at
all
that's that's what the transgender
debates about well how do you know how
do you know that Bruce Jenner really
isn't a woman
can you and your your answer might be
well because
every physical sign
points to his being a man
and then the modern Libs will say well
yeah but how do you know you can trust
those signs
how do you know that those really
signify anything at all
so what this becomes a debate over
is
not even just can you trust your
faculties of perception it even becomes
a debate over or say
epistemological realism and
nominalism are there really
such things as man and woman and leftist
ears tumbler and microphone or is there
just kind of stuff or they're just
particulars and when we try to broaden
those out into categories even the
category of man even the category of
woman even the category of Asian that
all kinds of breaks down what is it
these are debates that are not new
exactly they've cropped up in the
history of civilization
but when they've cropped up we've had to
deal with them they've led to crises I
mean there's one in particular cropped
up it really cropped up in the 11th and
12th century and then it came to a head
in the early 13th century called the
albigensian crisis which was there was
this movement of people called the
albigensians who believe that the
physical world was entirely evil the
spiritual world was entirely good and so
you shouldn't get married if you're
going to have sex at all it should just
be in concubineage you know it should
just be in these kind of temporary
relationships I guess now we call that
cohabitation it you should not have
children you should not do anything
permanent you should you should just try
to die off basically
that is
an idea that if left unchecked will
destroy civilization
and very nearly destroyed Western
Civilization now we're facing a similar
idea
it's a similar idea it in many ways it's
just the new version of this idea and so
are we going to deal with this seriously
or
if we start talking about it seriously
are we going to be labeled genocidal
maniacs and kicked out of the Public
Square and told stop thinking about that
well the stakes
are much higher than we are told we are
told that the stakes are oh just let
anybody do whatever they want to do who
cares not hurting you we can't look you
know you don't know anything I don't we
don't know very much you know maybe that
woman's Asian maybe she just identifies
as Asian I don't know who knows who
knows well if we don't know anything
then
we're not going to have a civilization
we're going to very quickly forget the
civilization that we once had the rest
of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it I have my
trusty iPad I'm speaking to the creme de
La Creme member segment here we've got
one last headline that Mr Davies wanted
me to get to which I have not yet seen
head on over to dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh